you think part of the reason that there  are so many people who are zinc  deficient is because they're eating  plants or anything that's too high in  phytic acid phytic acid is a major cause  but frankly glyphosate is probably a  bigger cause or roundup as it's known is  this amazing herbicide that destroys  soil and we have this habit of spraying  it on garbanzo beans and wheat on most  grains before we harvest them because it  makes them dry up more quickly at the  end of the season so especially in the  u.s the average person now is getting  about a pound a year of this weed killer  that affects your gut bacteria and it  unfortunately also is a chelator of zinc  so i think that's why okay that's very  interesting so